hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his lecture what is metaphysics there
is one mood or affective state that
Martin Heidegger is going to make
particularly central and he's doing this
precisely because as he says the other
moods which can place us within beings
as a whole the totality of being they
they miss something that the that
anxiety is able to in some way encounter
and there is what Heidegger is calling
the nothing that needs now other moods
as he says conceal this the the mood of
anxiety does not he wants from the very
beginning to make sure there's no
confusion about what we're talking about
when we're using this term anxiety or
angst and so we need to begin by looking
at some of the distinctions that he's
going to make he tells us that there we
go
we don't mean the quite common
anxiousness ultimately reducible to
fearfulness so he's treating anxiety and
fear as distinct modalities of some you
know basic thing which he says all too
readily comes over us anxiety is
basically different from fear why we
become afraid in the face of this
particular being that threatens us in
this or that particular respect so we
can say that we have in a very you know
broad sense we might say I'm feeling
anxious about finances or I'm feeling
anxious about this date that I'm going
to go on or I'm feeling anxious about
the interview that I have coming up or I
just feel anxious about you know what
the future holds for me and what
Heidegger is saying is well in many of
those cases we might not be talking
about anxiety as such we're probably
talking about fears that if we do enough
analysis we can pinpoint what are you
worried about it's going to happen on
the date oh I think that I might spill
my coffee and get it all over my
pants and embarrass myself because then
I'll look like a jackass or I might walk
into the interview and forget all of the
things that I I put in my mind to think
about this company and the responses
that I want to get we can go on and on
those are distinct things that happen
within being as a whole but they pertain
to a particular region of being or
particular beings that we can pinpoint
anxiety is something more global he's
going to say fear he says possesses this
trait of being fear in the face of in
fear for we can also fear feel fear for
something like I'm afraid for my child
I'm afraid for my car I'm afraid for my
finances I'm afraid for my computer when
I take it in to be repaired says he who
fears and is afraid is captive to the
mood in which he finds himself striving
to rescue himself from this particular
thing it becomes unsure of everything
else and completely loses a tent so
there can be a global response to fear
in terms of being as a whole but it's
not the same one as anxiety which is
going to reveal to us be nothing
he said the anxiety does not let such
confusion arise much to the contrary a
particular a peculiar calm pervades it
it is an anxiety in the face of and that
he's got dot dot dot but it's not
anxiety in the face of this particular
thing it is a more global feeling or
emotion or attunement however you want
to discuss it that pertains to beings as
a whole and he says anxiety in the face
of is always anxiety for but not for
this or that it's got a certain as
Heidegger says indeterminate Ness and so
it's not a lack of determination it's
not as if you're being you know
superficial or not analyzing things far
enough and saying well what are you
anxious about if it's really anxiety
there is no one single thing that you
can focus in on there is going to be a
back and forth that will Center on the
human person but slipping away from the
shoe
in person so it's concerned with the
world of being and where we are as
acting persons within that that world so
he says in anxiety and there's a very
famous passage in Heidegger's work one
field ill-at-ease and the german for
that is item in Heimlich a lot has been
made out of this one Heimlich kite
that's involved in anxiety where I could
worry so much about that here although
that's an interesting subtopic he asked
well what is it that makes one feel ill
at ease we can't say when we feel
genuine anxiety as a whole it is so for
one and now here he begins a kind of
phenomenological description of what
anxiety feels like and he's being very
metaphorical here he is using terms of
value and he's using even more terms of
spaciality and movement these are not to
be taken literally as if somehow beings
are changing their location in relation
to us this has to be understood
effectively and metaphorically a very
important point right here so he goes on
and he uses he talks about one of the
first traits of this all things and we
ourselves sink into indifference so
that's a value term right there in
difference notice what he's saying all
things the totality of beings and
ourselves sink into and difference it's
not just that we remain exactly what we
are and the totality of beings sink into
indifference we ourselves also sink into
indifference we are in the midst of the
totality of beings he goes on and he
says this is not in the sense of mere
disappearance now he starts using
spatial terms in this very receding
things turn towards us so there's a back
and forth kind of metaphorical movement
taking place here in anxiety things are
slipping away from us it's another way
that he talks about it he also says
retreating
if they are deliberately moving from us
you know or are fleeing us but they also
are turned towards us
at the same time so he says this
receding of beings as a whole that
closes in on us now notice it's closing
in on us that presses us we can get no
hold on things each thing that we try to
reach for or if we grasp it it loses its
significance it doesn't turn out to be
what we had hoped it would be so this is
a key aspect of what Heidegger is
calling anxiety again I want to stress
that these are metaphorical ways of
talking about it there really are no
other ways of talking about it that can
capture the experience of anxiety now he
told us anxiety reveals the nothing we
hover he says in anxiety now that's what
we're doing we are feeling anxiety but
feeling anxiety also means that we have
a sort of spaciality we are hovering in
it it leaves us hanging he says because
it induces the slipping away of beings
as a whole here is where we get to the
other side of the analysis he says that
we ourselves are slipping away from
ourselves so we find ourselves unable to
count upon ourselves unable to entirely
recognize ourselves or what we do
recognize we realize is something
different than what we thought we had
there you can understand this in many
different ways you know if you like
talking about the ego you could say that
portions of the ego reveal themselves to
be fabricated or not to be genuinely
what one is and he says this implies
that we ourselves we humans who are in
being in the midst of being slip away
from ourselves at bottom it's not as if
is that as though you or I feel at ease
rather it is this way for someone it is
this way for what Heidegger calls design
existence being there human being in the
altogether on
settling experience he says pure design
is all that is left there when you feel
genuine anxiety you are having a
revelation often a very uncomfortable
revelation isn't it of what it is that
you are when you strip away all of the
other stuff that you think is is you
that you are convinced is you you are
design
I am design Heidegger is design and we
are our own design but we share this you
know fundamental set of possibilities as
well and this can be quite difficult for
people so he talks here and I'm not
going to go into any detail about this
about you know how we try to evade
anxiety by chattering and you know
trying to to do things to distract
ourselves from us he's got many analyses
of this and being in time we don't need
to go into this coming back to what he's
saying with the fundamental fundamental
mood of anxiety we've arrived he says
that that occurrence in human existence
in which the nothing is revealed how is
it with the nothing now I've got nothing
on the board twice I don't want you to
think that these are two different
nothing's as if we can somehow count up
nothing I just want to stress that the
nothing is revealed within the totality
of beings but also in the the human
person design plus nothing you can
always add nothing to anything in this
sort of metaphysics so he says the
nothing reveals itself in anxiety but it
does not reveal itself as a being it is
not given as an object and he stresses
to us anxiety is no kind of grasping of
the nothing you can't hold the nothing
in your hand but all the same the
nothing is there for design the nothing
reveals itself in and through anxiety
that that is our fundamental way of
grasping than nothing this is a key
insight on the part of Martin Heidegger
here and he says that in anxiety that
nothing is encountered at one with being
as a whole so he's going to stress to us
that this does not take place by simply
negating being as a whole something that
we already looked at in terms of
insufficient definition of the nothing
and the way in which the intellect does
it it's also not done by annihilating
being as a whole reducing everything to
nothing because we are in the face of
beings they do have being they use this
and yet the nothing is also there so
here Heidegger is going to coin a term
that a lot of people have actually taken
umbrage with by talking about nihill
aiding he says that the nothing Neelix
literally makes nothing it's not the
same thing as annihilating to reduce to
nothing the nothing nothing's is how it
has been put and we're going to have to
look at what that actually means what is
neo lating but at this point as far as
this topic goes what is going on is
anxiety this mood that we feel as human
beings is revealing to us not only the
nothing along with the totality of
beings with this modality of receding
and turning towards us pressing us in
different all these other great
descriptors that we had but also that
the nothing is doing something or it's
literally doing nothing it's nothing if
we want to stretch language quite
further what that is has yet to be
determined but that is being revealed to
us by anxiety
you